안녕하십니까. 치밀턴 여러분. 행복한
투자을 함께하는 체슬리 모닝 브리프
7월 6일 새로운 한 주의 시작
월요일 1부를 시작하겠습니다.
전일 지난주 금요일이죠. 중국 시장
어떻게 됐는지 우리 왕정부장님과 함께
알아보겠습니다.
>> 네. 지난주 금요일은 대형주
반등하면서 사회지수 플러스 0.37%
37% 올라왔고요. 흥성태그 지수
플러스 1%을 상승했습니다. 증시
거대금 3.2조한 수준을 유지했어요.
업종별 좀 보시면 자유소비제 에너지
산업제 업종인 강세 배웠고 반면은
필수 소비제케이션 IT 업정이 약세
배웠습니다. 5월 전기차 수출 데이터
하조 등행으로 전기차 권연주 지난주
금매 좀 많이 오라하고요. 메아디는
5.85% 올라고 상 자동차는
2.3% 요시 동료는 6.7%마
7%마 지구는 9% 가이 올라왔어요.
어 컵에든 기대감으로 에너지 권용주
진정주 개멸도 올라왔습니다. 배터리
최는 1중 7% 올라고 신호펜는 +
2% 눈석화는 5% 올라왔어요. 뭐
에너지 관련주 뭐 태별한 이슈가
없습니다.
>> 음
>> 올 기계 판매 예상 지상 후회 등
소식으로 기계 권조도 강세
보되었습니다. 3일 중공 없는 자정은
5% 올라고 성공 기계는 3% 가격이
올라왔어요. 요리 선유 가격 추가
인상도 기대담으로 요리 선유 관련주도
올라왔습니다. 중국 거선은 자정 4%
올라고 정재 테크는 4% 고제 신재는
4% 올라왔어요. 어 PCB 및
CCR 권 관련주도 반등했습니다.
생인테크는 5.8% 동생 청면 5%
청률 7% 호전 주시도 3.7%
나왔습니다. 다만 역사 신거치는
아니고요. 목일 그때는 많이
빠졌습니다.
애플 관련주도 돈반 상승하고요. 공업
불려는 1% 3천.8%
올라왔어요. 반면은 건통신 관주들이
또 조금은음 보칭했습니다. 종재
5천은 -2.4% 4% 중재 테크는
-2.6% 버스는 빠졌어요. 신념물
구제 금된 1비P조는 하나였습니다.
구제 금리는 2BP 하라고 외안
환율는 염정쿠퍼센 소폭
잘산되었습니다.음
>> 감사합니다. 지난주에 제가 2부
진행할 때 오과장한테 드렸던 질문
똑같이 우리 왕부장님께도 드려보고
싶은데 어 중국도 큰틀에서 보면은
IT 솔님인데 계속 어 그렇기 때문에
상대적으로 수급적 피해로 아이 기업이
이렇게까지 주가가 하락하는게 말이
되나 싶은 종목들 아마 있으실 것
같은데
>> 그런 종목 있으시다면 한두 개 정도
그리고 왜 그렇게 어 지나친 저평가
영역으로 들어갔다고 생각하시는지 좀
팁 좀 얻어 볼까요? 아, 네.
초반제 딱 승각 나오는 회사는
텐센트예요.
>> 텐센트.
>> 어. 어. 우리 시총 상위 종목인데.
>> 어, 맞아요. 조금만 뭐 그 시간에
자연 회자는 볼 필요가 없다고
생각하고 있고요.
>> 승선 이런 회자는 시가 좀 크고요.
그리고 지금 포드는 11배밖에
없습니다. 캐스 투자에 대한 걱정이
되게 많으니까 주관는 계속 빠졌어요.
>> 다만 그 실전은 쿠파꾸바 나올 수
있습니다. 네. 음.
>> 그런 회사는 딱피로 보고 있고 그리고
쇼미 이런 회산은 또 볼 필요가
있다고 생각하고 있고요. 쇼미 지금
버드 피안을 14배가지가 내려왔어요.
다만 역산상 최하던 수준은 열배
수준입니다. 야 빠질 수 있는 여유가
있지만
>> 실제 좀 분위가음 뭐 아마 시정
대비는 그렇게도 하회하지 않을 수
가능성 좀 있어요. 다만 요즘에
매물이 가격 오라 하니까 시 뭐
투자자들이 걱정이 너무 많아서 주가를
계속 뒤신 분이 했습니다.
>> 미국 기업은 저희가 어 에셋 헤비냐
에셋 라이트냐 뭐 이렇게 구분하기도
하고 그래서 반도체 기업은 엄청
좋은데 소프트웨어 기업들은 안 좋고
이렇게 많이 구분을 양분해서
말씀드리는데 두꺼이 아시아 쪽에서는
플랫폼 기업들이 주가가 안 좋은 거
같아요. 한국도 오가장이 아 네이버가
밸루에이션이 이렇게까지 내려왔다 이런
얘기 했던 기억이 있습니다. 네.
>> 그런 것들 계속해서요 반작용일 때 또
그런 밸류에이션을 회복할 때 어떨지
주목해서 봐야 되는 종목이니까
10센트는
>> 어 꼭
>> 저도 관심 있게 보겠습니다. 워낙
했주라
>> 그렇죠. 들어 올릴 때는 또 가장
먼저 주목 받을 수 있을 것
같아서요.
>> 이슈 종목은 국자 재료.
>> 네. 국자 재료는 처음으로 가져오는
회사였고요.이 지금은이 회사는 시가
중간는 20조원 되고 포드 피는
높아요. 98배 수준입니다.
>> 음. 어 중국대 세라믹 그 소재 제조
회사고요. 주요 MRCC 등 세라미
소재 승참이 판매하고 있습니다. 주요
고객으로 보시면 전개 폴리스톤 오라타
교세라 삼환 정자 봉화테크 다
MLCC 관련주입니다. 1분기 매출는
동의 증가하고요. 수익이는 동의는
5% 증가하고 예성치 대비로 좀
보화수는 나왔어요. GP 마진
5.7% 나오고 MP 마진 13.9%
9% 나왔습니다. 동리 대비도 소폭
하라 했습니다. 주행 있는 그 원자재
가격 성 그리고 환자순 등 일성
요인으로 수위선 속 악화되었어요.이
회사는 선물 부단을가 인상
제시했어요. 개시했습니다. 그래서이
실전은 아마 2분기 부단을 방영할 수
있어요. 동산 현재는 야 1만 충독
MRCC 세라미 소재 승찬 능력
보유하고 있습니다. 연간은 5,000
규모의 AS법 촬영 MLCC 세미
소재 승찬 능력 화대에 추진하고
있고요. 기종의 40% 이미 작년
말부터는 영상을 개시했습니다. 나머지
60%는 올해 말부터는 영상을 그
시작할 예정입니다.
>> 음. 올해 3월부터 5월까지 MLC
업체는 업체 가격 인상했습니다.
특히는 모라타 삼성 전기는 각하가
10%부터 135% 인상하고요.
따라서는 MLCC 세라믹 소재 가격도
약 10%부터 15% 정도 인상
결정했어요.
이번 일반은 MRC라미 소재는 든단던
요만 외토의 7만 외 정도됐다는 GP
33% 나오고 있습니다. 다만 A의
소보용 MLC라미 소재는 심해야
됩니다. 그래서이 대충 50% 60%
더 비싼 가격을 팔고 있고요. GP
마진도 45% 50% 나오고
있습니다.
글로벌 수유 호조 그리고 공급 제한
등용으로 정량 마키는 동산을 기압
부채 경우는 전분기 대비 215%을
급정하고요. 1분기도 비슷한 수준을
유지하고 있습니다. 어 GP워크
리포트 나오고요. 어 거가 거부가
같이 매출 비중 화대 ASP 인상등
관점으로 매수 의견을 제시했습니다.
원래부터 내년 내후 EPS는가 염증
852 2호 위로 추정되었고 지정
대비 각가 1% 22% 28% 정도
상승 조정했습니다.
>> 내년은 88배 PR 전개해서 DP는
130p 요구한 종료 제시했습니다.
지전 대비는 125% 정도 큰 포로
상형 조정하고 있고 어제 종가 대비
50%돼 있습니다.음
>> 감사합니다. 네.
>> 저기 두 번째 줄에 적어주신 것처럼
지금 MLCC 관련한 전 세계적인
업체들, 무라타, 삼성전기, 기판,
교세라 뭐 이런 등등이 어이 국자
재료의 고객사들이고이
>> 고객사들의 업항이 워낙 좋고이
고객사들 제품에 단가가 올라가다
보니까
>> 여기에 납품하는 재료를 만들어 만드는
국자 재료도
>> 어 납품 가격 인상하고 그러니까
그것들이 어 실적과 밸루에이션에 지금
>> 계속해서 서 반영이 돼서 주가가 밑에
보시는 PBR 차트처럼 급등하고 있는
거 같습니다. 맞아요.
>> 어 중국 개인 투자자 특히 입장에서
아 삼성전기 사야 되는데 무라타 사야
되는데라는 아이디어가 있는데
>> 어 이게 국경을 넘어가야 되는 투자기
때문에 적 할 수가 없다면이 기업
사면 되는 겁니다네.
>> 어네 외국인은 왜냐면부터 시작하니까
외국인 살 수 없는 주식 개인으로 살
수 없는 주식고요.
>> 개인이 살 수 없죠. 항상이 회자를
언급할 때는 [콧방귀] 그 군하는
회자도 하나 많이 얘기해요. 그냥 그
회사가 그 대주
>> 전자재료
>> 맞아요. 그 가치 얘기 많이 하고
있고요. 만약면 이런 거는 회사를
그렇게 많지 않다고 알고 있고이
회사는 전 세계 세라미 소재 기준으로
하면은 전 세계 아마 1등입니다.이
회사이 회사입니다. 거의 시장
잠매율는 거의 20% 20%보다
30% 수준이 됐고요. 그 세라미
소재 있잖아요. MRC도 있고 뭐
여러 여러 여러 여러 여러 가지 치과
쪽 로트도 다른가 있어요. 그래서
MLCG 정체이 회사 비중 20%
없어요.
>> 네. 그래서이 시장은 완지 않다고
생각할 수 있습니다. 음. 시장이
시장이 작아서 한 20%밖에 안 되는
아니면 어 워낙에 전방 산업이
다양해서 공급사들이 좀 이렇게 많이
분산돼 있다. 맞아요. 왜냐면 인호
회사는 그 이렇타 있잖아요. 자기도
세라미 소재 가지고 있어요.
>> 음
>> 그 수직 개업화로 되어니까 순수로
보면은이 호자는 1등이지만 개별 호자
다 자기 이런 사업을 가지고
있습니다. 음. 네. 예. 뭔가이
MLCC 기판 이런 업항의 가장
끝단에서 가장 베타가 높은 종목 중에
하나가 아닌가 하는 생각이 들고
맞아요.
>> 밸루에이션도 지금 포워드 기준으로
PER은 98회 그리고 북밸류는
10배를 넘었기 때문에
>> 이런 좋은 어떤 업항과 그 시장의
긍정적인 네러티브가 밸류에이션의 상당
부분 반영은 되어 있는 거 같다.
그런 생각은 또 듭니다. 네네는
유를해서
>> 투자해야 되지 않을까 하는 생각이
드는데
>> 동의해 주시는 거네
>> 맞습니다.
>> 오늘은이 직접 투자를 오늘 딱
결정해야 된다기보다는
>> 이런 업항에 이런 기업이 있다라는
관점으로 이해를 좀 하고 넘어가
보겠습니다.
>> 가상자산 보고 어 미국 시장 볼
텐데요. 오늘 순서가 조금 바뀐
이유는 어 미국이 전일 그러니까
금요일 날 휴장이었기 때문에 어 2부
시간에서 해 주셨던 내용들을 1부
시간 최일호 사장님과 알아보고 2분은
국내시장으로 바로 넘어가도록
하겠습니다. 1부에서 좀 부족한
내용이 있다면 2부에서 또 Q&A 할
수 있는 거니까 끝까지 좀 들어봐
주시고요. 우선 순서 바꿔서
가상자산부터 보겠습니다. 네. 가상
시장 말씀드리겠습니다. 어 72시간
가요 흐름 먼저 보시면요. 한
62,900불 정도까지를
돌파했습니다. 그래서 2011일
이평선이 한 62,300불에서
500불 정도 그 정도 라인이
되는데요. 그선 위에 우선 안착한
주말 흐름이었습니다. 그래서 굉장히
긍정적이다라고 단기 단편적으로 볼 수
있을 것 같고요. 하지만 밑에도 다
말씀드리겠지만 지금 이런 것들이 뭔가
어 대규모 매집의 흔적이나 아니면
위기를 기회를 삼는 그런 투자들의
흐름은 전혀 보이지 않고 있는
상황입니다. 그래서 그런 부분들은 어
주적할 필요가 있고 그런 것들
확인하고 어 위험자산 위험 자산 시장
선호에 대한 지금 바늘이 솔림이
아니라 전체적인 어 위험자 선호의
신호로 저희가 봐도 되지 않을까 하는
생각 갖고 있고요. 오른쪽 말씀
오른쪽 보시면 아까 말씀드린 것처럼
어 200주 이평선 가장 밑에 있는
빨간색 선을 이제 위에 안착을 한
수준이다라고 보시면 될 거 같고
일선을 지키는지만 저희가 확인하면
됩니다.
>> 어 밑에 내려오셔서 비트코인 퓨앤
그리드 인덱스 보시면 아스트도 극단
쪽 공포 구간 23 정도를 기록하고
있고요. 오른쪽 보시면 비트코인 현물
ETF 승유 순유 보시면 지난 한
주간은 어 금요일이 없어서 그런지
유출세가 그렇게 크진 않았다라고 볼
수 있을 것 같습니다. 어, 지난
목요일 날 기준으로 보면 220밀
정도가 유출이 됐고요. 지난 어, 한
주 동안은 520년 정도가 유출이
됐는데 이것도 예를 들어서 금요일
날도 있었다라고 하면 한 700밀리대
유출은 어, 기본적으로 있지 않았을까
하는 생각을 개인적으로 하고
있습니다. 어, 주요에 간단한 거
방금 말씀드렸던 거를 조금 설명드리고
드리고 넘어가면 될 거 같습니다.
어, 제목에 위기를 기회로 삼지 않은
투자들이라 이렇게 써 놨는데요.
패턴적으로 등락을 반복하면서
비트코인의 단기적인 바닥을 다지고
심리적 극단적 공포 구간을 매집의
기회로 활용하면서 리스크 대비 리턴이
큰 상황이 항상 연출이 되왔었습니다.
그래서 어 단기적으로 크게 하락했을
때마다 투자들은 조금 매집을 하면서
어 큰 리턴을 얻는 그런 상황들을
계속해서 연출을 됐었는데요. 하지만
지금 현재 상황에서 그런 힌트들이
발견되지 못하고 있습니다. 어, 최근
비트코인이 반등을 시작했는데 올해
3월과 좀 비슷한 상황인지를 확인을
위해서는 반대체 솔림으로이 관 그
반대체 솔림으로 관련 주식들이 상승할
때 소외되지 않고 상승하는 모습들이
있는지 추적을 해야 되는데 금요일
국내장에서는 어, 단편적이지만 그런
흐름이 이어졌다라고 판단을 할 수
있을 것 같습니다. 그래서 어,
비트코인 시장 자체가 금요일 날
반도체 쪽으로 쏠림이 있음에도
불구하고 어, 상승이 조금 나온
부분이 있었다. 하지만 그 밑에 사진
두 개를 제 설명드리려고 하는데요.
어, 마켓메이커 순유입이 있다라고
합니다. 그래서 마켓메이커 순입 그
차트를 보시면 왼쪽에 있는 노란색 선
같은 경우에는 극단적으로 이렇게
등락이 있는 부분에서도 대규모 매집의
흔적이 있습니다. 거래량이 확
나오면서 어 좀 이걸 살려고 하는 좀
모아가려고 하는 그런 수요가
있었는데요. 그래서 이번 근데
그렇지만 이번에 오른쪽 그 빨간색
선이 있는 수요를 보시면 하락하면서
그 극단적 공포의 구간을 매집에기로
삼지 않는 모습을 어 데이터적으로
확인할 수가 있을 것 같고요. 어,
또 다른 근거로서 오른쪽에 있는
OTC 바이사이드 유동성이라고 해서
어, 그니까 장 외 거래에서 비트코인
얼마나 많으고 있는지 이런 부분에
대한 체크를 이루어진다라고 보시면 될
거 같은데 어, 지난번에도 그 24년
이게 초중반인데요. 24년 왼쪽에
있는 오렌지 박스 쪽을 보시면 어 좀
등락 있을 때마다 어 장외의 거리가
활발하게 이루어지면서 그 유동성이 어
가장자 시장 또는 위험 자산단
시장으로 조금 유입되는 그런 그림이
보여줬다라고 하면 어 2025년
10월 이후로부터 해서 지금 하락이
나올 때마다 지금 그런 유동성이 어
유입되는 모습은 보이지 않고 있다라는
부분을 체크하실 수가 있을 것
같습니다. 그래서 어 지금 상승을
하고 있지만 그 상승의 여력이 어
뭔가 지금 적극적인 매집의 어 힌트나
매집의 증거다라고 보기보다는 어 뭔가
숏 커버나 어 그런 기술적인 요소가
좀 더 클 수 있다라는 점을 첨구하면
될 거 같고요. 그래서 아직
말씀드리고 싶었던 부분은 아직
위험자산 시장 어 그리고 전체 섹터
확산으로 해서 어 아직 주식 시장
전체 전반에이어서 약간 그런 것들이
턴오버 되지 않았다. 그러니까 조금
돌지 않았다라는 것을 말씀드리고
싶어서이 자료를 준비했습니다. 흑이
가장자한 시장에서 더 특정돼서 그렇게
말씀드릴 수 있을 것 같고요.
>> 어, 그리고 약속의 10월까지는 딱
한 분기 정도 남았습니다. 75%
정도 왔기 때문에 어, 한 91일
그래서 딱 한 세 달 정도 남았다.이
정도 지금 태킹 주이기 위해서
가져왔습니다. 이상입니다.
감사합니다. 저희가 주식 낙폭과대
이런 것들 볼 때 어 주가가 지나치게
급락하면 가격도 보고 또 밸루에이션도
보고 어 이렇게 가격의 어떤 지지선
뭐 이런 것도 보고 하는데 그것과
더불어서 꼭 보는게 어 아주 많이
낙폭이 커졌다고 했을 때 거래량이
실려야
>> 진바닥이다. 그런 얘기를 하기도
하는데
>> 그렇죠. 이건 진짜 여기는 사야지
이런 투자자들이 많다는 증거니까요.
그런데 그런 것들이 지금 보이지
않는다는 말씀을 해 주신 거 같아요.
마지막 표에서.
>> 네. 상승이 있음에도 불구하고 그것
때문에 상승하는게 아니다라는 걸 좀
말씀드렸습니다. 음. 그래서 어떤
수급 그리고 거래량까지 보면 약속의
10월까지는 당분간 어떤 지지선 레벨
정도만 지키면
>> 우리가 약속의 10월을 계속 약속할
수 있다.
>> 맞습니다. [웃음]
>> 네. 이렇게 정리하고 보도록 보고
넘어가도록 하겠습니다.
어, 미국 시장 볼 텐데요. 오늘
미국 시장 보통 월요일 날 해 주시는
밸루에이션 이런 것들 봐야 하기
때문에 8시 전후에 일부를 보통
마치는데 그보다는 시간이 조금 길어질
수 있겠습니다.
>> 예.
>> 부사장님께 지난 한 주 동안 또 어떤
변화들이 있었는지 꼼꼼히 들어보도록
하겠습니다.
예.
지난주 금요일 미국 시장 후장이었지만
유럽 시장은 열렸고요. 유럽의 주요
종목들 보면은 대체로 올랐습니다.
ASML이나 NXP 반도체 어뭐 이런
것들 배시 뭐 이런 어 IT 종목들
위주로 좀 올랐던 거 같고요.
>> 어 지난주 금요일 날 장애 안 열렸기
때문에 4거래일 동안의 미국 시세라고
보시면 될 거 같고요. SP 500이
1.8% 상승했고 12개월 보드
EPS는 0.3% % 상향
조정됐습니다. YTD로 9.3%
올랐는데 아 두 자리 속 오르기가 좀
어렵네요. 자기 4D EPS가
19.5% 어 상향 조정됐고요.
7월 2일 기준으로
포워드 PER은 20.19에
거래되고 있고 PBR은 5.74배
거래되고 있습니다. 지난주 등락
보면은
SP 500은 1.8% 올랐는데 그
기업분의 대부분이 아 빅테크였습니다.
Nv디아가 1.2% 애플 8.8%
올랐고요. 구글 6.7% %
마이크로소프트 4.7%
아마존 4.3%
로드컴은 1.3% 하락했고요. 메타가
5.9% 올랐고요. 테슬라도 간만에
3.6% 올랐습니다. 그 외에 보면은
어 마이콘 테크날로지가 13.8%
8% 하락했는데
시총 32 중에서 반도체 지수들
반도체 종목들이 다 하락을 했습니다.
밑에 어 빨간 줄 쳐 놓은 거 보면은
마이크론을 비롯해서 인텔도 한
6.2% 하락했고요.
>> AMD도 3.8% 램 리서치도
7.3% % 하락했습니다. 옆에 이제
YTD를 보면은 대체로 한 세리수
이상 상승한 부분이 눈에 띄는데 많이
오른 거에 대한 좀 아 로테이션의
빌미가 될 만한 그리고 솔림의 완화가
될 만한 이슈가 지난주에 메타
관련돼서 어 나왔었고요. 그에 따른
결과라고 보시면 될 것 같습니다.
>> 음
>> 아 버크가 1.8% 8% 올랐고 그
우리도 그렇지만 미국에서도 금융가
최근 단기적으로 좀 오르고 있는
상황입니다. JP목은 1.6%
상승했고 반면에 월마트는 3.3%
하락했습니다. 위익 쪽 보시면은 크게
뭐 변화된 거는 없고 잔잔하게 상향
조정되고 있는 그런 모습인데 마이콘
테크놀로지가 2.1% 정도가 또
상향됐습니다.
나중에 보시기면 알겠지만 하이닉스하고
삼성전자도
그 주관 기준으로 이익 주정치가
상향되는 모습이 관찰됐고요.
PR 보시면은 많이 낮아져 있는
상황인데
Nv디아가 18.4배, 애플이
32.7배인데 7배인데
>> 음
>> 얼마 전까지만 하더라도 엔비디아 바로
밑에 알파벳 그 구글이 따라오면서 뭐
1등이 되니 많이 하는 얘기들이
있었는데 알파벳이 좀 밀렸습니다.
그러면서 애플이 다시 시청 2위
자리를 차지하고 있고요. 그리고
마이크로소프트가 한 20배 정도에
거래되고 있고 아마존 22.3배
로드값이 21.5배까지
하락을 했습니다. 그리고 메타
15배, 테슬라 118.5배,
일라일리 30배,
마이콘 테크놀로지 7배 그리고 어
버크쇼 SA 25.7배 JP무
14.5배 오펜 전부 다 어
비테크들을 비롯해서 시총 상위주들
밸류에이션은 조금 한단게
좀 다운그레이드 된 느낌이 있고요.
>> 다만 애플 같은 경우는 한 30배 좀
거래가 되고 있는 그런 상황입니다.
아 섹터 흐름 보면은 어 자유소 비제
헬스케어 커뮤니케이션 금융 섹터
내에서 대형주 중심으로 어 성과의
기여가 돼 있고요. 그리고 앞면에
필반 지수 에너지 부동산은 조정을
받았습니다. 일반 지수 아 지난주에
4.4% 정도 하락을 했고요. 어
이번 달에 11.4% % 정도 어
하락한 상황입니다.
EPS는 계속해서 어 상향 조정이
되고 있고 되고 있는 상황이라고
보시면 될 것 같습니다.
경제 지표 보시면은 이번 주에 ISM
서비스 PMI가 나오고 FMC
의사록이 나오고 어 주간 고용이
나오는데 FMC 의사록에서
약간 톤 자체를 느낄 수 있을 만한
매시가 있을지는 모르겠는데
9일로 어 예정이 돼 있고요. 기업
실적 보면은 특별히 큰 종목들은
아닌데 리바이스라든지
펩시코 그리고 델타 정도가 우리가 알
만한 기업이라고 보시면 될 것
같습니다.
기타 쪽에서 하이닉스의 ADR 성장이
7월 10일로 예정되 있고요. 아
물론 내일 삼성전자에 잠정 실적
발표도 예정이 돼 있습니다. 그리고
이번 주에 TSMC 6월 매출이
나오면서 2분기 매출이 확정이 될
예정인데 2분기 매출이 참고
참고적으로
39.6빌리언 달러가 시장에서
컨센서스로 형성이 돼 있고요. Q큐로
10.4%, YY로 30.6%
정도 어 늘어난 수치입니다.
금리 쪽 보시면은 뉴체 10년물이
11b가 상승하면서 4.48%를
기록했고 2년물이 5bp 상승하면서
4.14% 상당기 금지차가 35p을
기록하고 있습니다. 기대 인플레이션은
3b
상승한 2.23% 그리고 실질 금리는
8bp 상승한 2.24% 24% 정도
기록하고 있습니다.
하일드가 3vp 정도 어 상승한
6.98%고요. %고요. 하일드
스프레드는 지난주에 한 8b 정도
하락한 2.75%를 기록하고
있습니다. 그래서 전반적으로 명목
금리가 조금씩 지난주에 오르면서
어 4.5%까지
근접해 있는 상황이고요.이 이
다음 주에 어 CPI가 발표가 되고
이번 주에 ISM 서비스 쪽에서
물가에 대한 어떤 시그널을 어 줄 수
있는 상황이 나올 수 있을 것
같습니다.
상품 시장 보면은 유가가 지난주에는
0.7% 정도 하락한
68.76달러고요.
우리가 4 0.4% 상승한
6.17달러를 7달러를 기록했습니다.
미국 천연가스는 1.1% 하락한
3.24불인데 유럽 천연가스가
10.3%가 한 주 만에 올랐는데 뭐
바닥에서 좀 반등한 거긴 하지만 유럽
쪽이 지금 폭염이 계속되면서 냉방용
전력 수요가 급증하고 있다고 합니다.
그런 이유로 45.34유로를
유를 기록을 했습니다.
외한 시장 보면은 어 달러 인덱스가
0.5% 하락한 100.86을
기록했고요.
달러 같은 경우는 0.4% 하락한
1529.2원.
그리고 달 유로 달러 같은 경우는
1유로당 1.143달러를
기록했고요.
달러 N 같은 경우는 0.23%
23% 하락한 161.37을
기록했습니다. 그래서 달렌덱스가 소폭
좀 낮아지면서 주요 통화가 소폭
강세로 가는 흐름이 관찰됐습니다.
아 코스피 주가 보시면은 최근 일주에
[목을 가다듬음] 한 3.8% 정도
어 하락을 했고요. 12개월 포워드
EPS는 4.5% 정도 사용 조정됐고
YTD로 91.9%가 %가 상승한
상태입니다. 12개월 포워드 EPS가
167.6%가
상향 조정되면서
상s 상향폭이 올해 상당합니다. 어
7월 3일 기준으로 코스피 PER은
7.25배, 2.5배, PBR은
2.3배를
기록하고 있습니다.
삼성전자 하이닉스, SK스퀘어,
삼성전기 이렇게 한네 종목이 어
하락을 했는데 뭐 정도의 차이는
있겠지만
YT로 보시면은
세 자릿수 이상 하락한
>> 상황에서 어 조정이 나왔다고 보시면
될 거 같고요. 나머지
탐성 생명도 올해 143% 하락했지만
어 지난주에 11.4% 4%
하락했지만 143%가
상승한 상태고 SK도 15%
하락했지만 169%가
YT로
상승했고
LG 전자도 2.5% 하락했지만
107% 정도 상승한 상태입니다.
그다음에 어 지난주에 상승한
종목으로는
현대차 2.4% LG엔솔 9.4% %
그리고 어 삼성 바이오 5.8% 하나
에어로가 16.2% 상승했고요. 현대
중공업이 2.3% 상승했습니다.
이익 보시면은 삼성전자 하이닉스가
3.6% 3.9% 상향 조정됐고요.
SK스퀘어 6.1% 1% 상향
주정됐고 삼성전기 5.1% 아
5.0% 상향 주정됐는데음
주가가 빠짐에도 불구하고 계속 이익
주정치는 어 상향 조정이 되면서 현재
삼성전자는 12개월 포워드 PR
기준으로 5.7배에 거래되고 있고
SK닉스는 6.2배에 어 거래되고
있는 상황입니다.
아 기타 SKS케어 5배 수준에
거래되고 있고요. 삼성전기가
75.8배 8배 현대차 10.5배
LG엔솔 96.1배
삼성생명 20.6배 삼성물산
23.3배 삼성 바이오 32.6배
하나에어로 23.3배 배 현대중공업
18배에 거래되고 있습니다.
국내 금리도 조금씩 올랐는데 10년물
기준으로 8b 상승한 4.2% 3년물
기준으로 3BP 상승한 3.75%
그리고 장당 금일차가 45b를
유지하고 있고요. 투자자 예탁금이
지난주에 제법 좀 많이 빠졌는데요.
7조 정도 감소한 119.9조 구조.
그리고 신용자가 4,억 정도 감선
37.7조원이고요.
아 주간 1평균 거래대금도
10조가 감소한 50.1조를 1조를
기록했습니다. 그래서 지난주에 조금
슬로우한 장 분위기를 어 대변하듯이
증시 주변 자금도 조금 슬로우한 그런
상황이었고요. 이번 주에 뭐 매크로
지표가 뭐 특별히 있는 것은 아니고
국내 증시에서
삼성전자 실적 발표 그리고
ADR로 상장될 SK 하이닉스의 흐름
그리고 TSMC의 흐름 어 요런 약간
반도체 쪽이 그동안 좀 한 2주 정도
어 조정을 받은 이후에 어 분위기를
반시킬 수 있는지 어 체크할 수 있는
변수들이 어 있을 예정이니까
부분들 좀 잘 살펴보면 될 것
같습니다.
>> 이상입니다.
>> 감사합니다. 오랜만에 부사장님하고
월요일마다 해 주시는 밸류에이션 관련
지표도 쭉 보고 있는데요. 몇 가지만
좀 여쭤보고 넘어갈게요.
>> 우선
>> 어 첫 페이지에 미국 시장 SMP
500 기준으로 밸루에이션 주셨는데
PER은 20.1고
PBR은 5.74입니다.
>> 물론 이제 미국 시장 밸류에이션 볼
때 저희가 금리 수준이라든지 전체적인
방향이 뭐 경제가 지금 올라가는
단계냐 아니면 하향하는 단계냐 건
상황이냐 뭐 이런 거 봐야 되는데 어
직관적으로 SMP 500 밸루에이션이
20배 미만이면 어 최근 5년
10년은 늘 매수 구간이었던 것
같아요. 예. 그래서 어 뭐 ROE
수준, 뭐 폭밸류 수준 뭐 이런 거
어 강론으로 들어가서 다 보면은 또
뭐 이렇게 그때그때마다 해석이 다를
수 있겠으나 그래서 SMP 500이
한 20배 정도 수준이니까
>> 어 필라델피아 반도체 지수와 관련되
있는 종목들은 엄청 변동성을 보였으나
어 큰 틀에서 미국 시장이 그냥
지수는 얌전했던 이유는 여기
있었겠다라는 생각도 해 봤습니다.
>> 예. 네, 그렇습니다. 필반지수가
아, 필반지수가 이제 전체 미국
시장에서 차지하는 비중 자체는 한 어
15%고요. 그리고 SNP
500대에서
어, 필반지수 아, 저 반도체
종목들이 또 있거든요. 그게 좀 꽤
올라왔습니다. 한 19.9% 9%
정도 되더라고요. 뭐 20% 정도 어
되는데 그럼에도 불구하고 이제
우리나라 같은 경우는 한 5, 60%
정도 반도체가 전체 시장에 영향을
주는데 미국 같은 경우는 한 20%
정도 영향을 주기 때문에 그 비중
자체가 적고 변동성이 반도체 쪽에서
생긴다고 하더라도 전체 시장에는
그렇게 우리나라보다는 상대적으로
영향력은 작다고 보시면 될 거 같고
>> 그 반대급으로 또 빅테크들이 한 어
시총상이 한 열 개 종목이 한 38%
정도 차지하고 있거든요. 어 그
비중에서 어 지난주에 어 반등을
보이다 보니까 반도체에서 크게
변동성이 나왔음에도 불구하고 어
빅테크 쪽 큰 종목들 이제 구경제
주식들이 어 그 부분을 어 메이크업해
주면서 어 지수 자체는 좀 오르는
그런 현상이 어 발생을 했고 어
반도체 위주로 가지고 계셨던 분들은
조금 쌓했지만 어 전체적으로 지수
상황은 양호했다 이렇게 정리를 할 수
있을 것 같습니다. 네. 밑에 섹터
흐름도 좀 여쭤보고 싶은데요. EPS
변화 추위를 계속 잘 보여 주시니까
>> 뭐 반도체 IT 이런 쪽은 어 당연히
좋을 거 같고
>> 그 밖에 어 여기 이렇게 이익이
그래도 견조하게 늘어나는데 멀티플만
많이 조정받아나 하는 섹터 한두 개
골라 주실 수 있을까요?
어 아무래도
어 커뮤니케이션 쪽에서 그 지금
구글이
>> 네
>> 아 24배에 거래되고
>> 베타가 15배에 거래되거든요. 음.
음.
>> 어, 사실 메타 같은 경우 뭐 이익
증가율이나 어 매출 증가율 뭐 이런
거에는 그
여타 다른 섹터의 타 종목 대비해
가지고 어 그렇게 뭐 손색이 갈 건
없어요. 근데 이제 어 아시다시피
공격적인 캠팩스 증가가 이어지면서
프리캐시 플로가 좀 낮아질 거라고
감소할 거라고 또는 이제 마이너스가
될 거라고 시장에서 얘기하면서 지금
지나치게 한 15배 정도의 거래가
되고 있거든요. 그러면은 메타하고 그
프리캐시 플로 부분만 제외하면은
메타하고 비슷한 체력을 가진 다른
기업들이 15배를 받냐 그건
아니거든요.
>> 예. 그래서 어이 부분이 이제 지금
특수한 AI 사이클 상에서 어 저평가
또는 밸류에이션이 굉장히 눌려 있다고
생각이 들고요. 그리고 뭐 특별히 어
다른 부분에 있어서는
어
미국 시장에서 지금 그 AI가
차지하는 비중 자체가 SP 500으로
보면 어떤 식으로든 뭐 인프라든 어
소프트웨어든 하드웨어든 반도체 해
가지고 한 절반 정도 차지하고
있고요. 네. 그렇지 않은 구경제
섹터들이 한 절반 정도 차지하고
있습니다. 그렇게 본다면 어느 한 뭐
어느 한 쪽이 이제 어 고평가 적변가
있다라기보다도
아 그 AI 모멘텀에 의해서
>> 그 상반되는 어떤 어 퍼포먼스가 아
계속 이어지지 않을까라고 생각합니다.
그래서 AI 진영 쪽에 있는
어 큰 주식들이
그렇지 않은 주식들에 비해서 어
계속해서 어 퍼포먼스가 아 좋을 수
있고요. 아, 그렇지 않으면 그
반대편에 BAI 쪽에 있는 종목들이
번노멘탈이 좋고 어, 가격이 싸고
어, 밸루에이션 매력이 있다고
하더라도 모멘텀 쪽에서 어, 조금
어, 뒤쳐지게 된다면 한동안 조금
어, 주가가 더 소해지지 않을까라고
생각합니다. 그래서 미국 시장들
이렇게 잘 보면은 어 밸류에이션이 그
강조되거나 아니면 구경제 주식이
강조되는 상황 그리고 그런 주식들이
돋보이는 시기는 어 위기 상황
있잖아요. 이럴 테면 다컴버일 때나
>> 아 아니면은
>> 어 2008년 금융위 때나 아니면 그
금리가 굉장히 스파이크가 일어나서
2022년처럼 물가를 잡기 위해서
패드가 금리를 공격적으로 올릴 때나
이런 쪽은 어 그런 주식들이 현금
[목을 가다듬음] 현금 흐름이 굉장히
견조하고 어 밸루에이션도 유지될 수
있을 만한 어 체력을 가지고 있기
때문에 어 상대적으로 그렇지 않은
성장주에 비해서 에서 어 상당히
견조한 모습을 보이지만 어 정상적인
상황에서는 미국 시장에서는 그
밸류에이션보다는 어 이익 모멘텀 어
그리고 향후 성장 모멘텀이 얼마나
센가에 따라서 주가가 차별화되는
경향이 있는 거 같습니다.
>> 저도 100% 동의합니다. 미국
시장에 투자하고 있는 특히 기관
투자자들은 어 성장주가 아닌 그런
가치주 어떻게 보면 저배타주를
고른다고 하면 같은 선진 시장의 다른
국가에서도 많이 찾을 수 있을 것
같아요. 유럽이나 이런 데들의
밸루에이션은 훨씬 낮기 때문에
>> 그러지 않을까는 생각이 듭니다. 여기
실적 주요 발표 기업들 이제 보면
>> 어 델타 그리고 펩시코 이런 것들은
뭐 전반적인 어떤 경기 또는
>> 소비 심리
>> 소비 심리 뭐 이런 건데 리바이스는
>> 아 리바이스는 [웃음]
>> 저희 세대한테 아주 익숙한
>> 예 그 그렇게 하는데 이제 아 좀
익숙한 이름이라서 그냥 한번 보자
그런 차원에서 한번혹 체크해
놨습니다.
>> 혹시 또 깊은 함의가 있으셨는지
같습니다. 예. 어, 그리고 밑에이
[목을 가다듬음]
미국 이제 금리, 장단기 금리 하일드
스프레드 요런 것들은 저희가 미국
10년물 국채 금리나 2년물 국채
금리 이런 것들은 매일 체크해
드리니까 그때 펀더멘탈이나 심리를
말씀드리고 있는 거 같고요. 그
밖에요 금리 관련한 여러 가지 어
장기 지표들이나 아니면 추위에
대해서는 뭐 특이 사항은 없다.
그렇게 보고 넘어가면 될까요? 아,
그 약간 이제 그 지난주에 그
유가가 그렇게 많이 빠지진
않았습니다. 뭐 0.7% 7% 이렇게
하락하면서
그간 그
물가를 자극했던 유가의 하락 속도에
따라서 미국 체금리가 아 조금
하방으로 방향을는 듯하더니 지난주엔
조금 그 부분들이 좀 슬로했고요.
그리고 어 잘 생각했 보시면 이제
물가를 자극하는 것이 어 공급
사이드에서 유가 같은 비용 상승
요인도 있지만 또 수요인도 있잖아요.
>> 그래서 지금은
>> 어 수요 요인도 약간은 그 물가를
자극할 수 있을 만한 상황이 아닌가
싶습니다. 그 수요인은 이제 어 소비
요인도 있고 투자 요인도 있지만
소비는 최근에 이제 소비 심리가
그렇게 막 쏙 좋지는 않거든요.
그리고 어 1분기 GDP를 통해서
본다고 하더라도 어 1분기 GDP에
크게 기여한 것이 소비 쪽이 아니라
인간 투자 쪽이거든요. 기업 투자
쪽이기 때문에
>> 그런 쪽이 약간은 그 금리를 자악할
수 있는 요인으로 남아 있지 않나 아
요런 생각이 좀 듭니다. 그래서
어 이제어 그 별주분에서도
말씀드렸듯이 아 지금까지 그 미란
전쟁 이후에 에너지 가격이 CPI의
기한 부분이 어 1%가 넘거든요.
왜냐면 2% 어 수준에서 2% 수준의
CPI에서 4.2%까지 올라왔는데 그
부분을 이제 브레이크다운해 보면은
에너지가 한 1.5% 포인트 정도가
어 기열했습니다. 그래서 그 1.5%
5% 포인트가 뭐 시간이 걸리면서
어느 정도 낮아질지는 모르겠지만 그
부분이 좀 어 픽아웃
>> 한다면 어 그 비용 상승 요인에서의
어 물가를 푸시하는 부분이 좀
누구어들지 않을까라는 생각을 좀 하고
있습니다. 그러면서
>> 어 미국제 10년물도 여기서 더
상방으로 가기는 좀 어렵지 않을까
개인적으로 좀 그렇게 생각합니다.네
네. 사장님이 꼼꼼히 항상 체크해
주시니까 보면서 [콧방귀]
말씀드리도록 하겠습니다. 코아레지
유가까지다 말씀해 주셨고 국내 시장
보면
>> 어 미국은 제가 부사장님께 이렇게
녹가 들어서 그런지 모르겠는데 SMP
500 지수 설명해 주시고 밸류에이션
할 때 뭐 예컨대 지수가 얼마고
SMP 500의 EPS가 한
360불이니까
>> 그러니까 PR이 몇 배다 이런 식으로
설명해 주시는 거가 아주 그게
익숙한데
>> 한국은 그런 식의 설명을 저는 잘 못
들어봤던 거 같은데 지난 주말에 아
국내 전략 자료도 쭉 있다 보니까
이제
>> 어 한국의 코스피 EPS가 뭐
1,200원이다, 1,00원이다, 뭐
그렇게 얘기를 하면서
>> 그러니까 멀티플이 지금은 어 금융위기
이후에 제일 낮은 어 일곱배 초반까지
내려왔다. 뭐 이런 말씀을 하시는 것
보고
>> 아 이제 한국도 EPS로
>> 코스피를 설명하시는 분들이
생기시는구나라고 느꼈는데
>> 예,
>> 이미 그렇게 오래됐는데 제가 게러서
이제 본 건가요?
아, 이게 [목을 가다듬음]
그
그러니까 우리나라 같은 경우는 음,
복합 기업들이 많잖아요. 지주사도
많고.
>> 네.
그래서 이게 어
그 비곡은 그런 지주사나 복합 기업
이런 거 없이 그냥 어 그냥 단일
기업으로 본업만 하는 어 회사들을
그냥 상장시키는 스타일이고 그러니깐
영업 이익 그 영업 이익에서부터
순익 EPS까지
가는 그 과정 자체가 심플합니다.
근데 [목을 가다듬음]
그
대표님도 아시다시피 우리나라 같은
경우는
>> 어떤 기업이 20% 30% 가지고
있으면 그걸 연결해 가지고 100%
가지고 있는 것처럼 해서 예. 일단은
나오고 그 어 그 바텀라인으로 갈수록
그 지분만큼만 반영을 해주잖아요.
>> 그래서
>> 저는 개인적으로 어떤 면에 있어서는
그 바텀라인으로
평가해 주는 것이 맞다고 생각을
하거든요. 왜냐하면 영업 이익으로 가
>> 영업 이익 수순에서 이제 하다 보면은
>> 어 지분법 아 연결 회사들 같은
경우는 영업 이익 100%로 그냥 해
주잖아요. 그렇기 때문에 이게 약간
좀 외곡이 생길 수 있다는 생각은 좀
들어요. 개인적으로. 그래서 어떤
이유에서든지 그 그근데 워론버펫 같은
경우는 그 밑으로 가면 갈수록 뭐 그
영업 외실,
영업의 이익 뭐 이런 일시적인 것들
때문에 밑에 그 바텀라인보다는 영업
이익 쪽이 더 어 좀 더 설명력을
많이 가진다고 어 얘기를 하고
있고요. 그래서 영업 이익이 참 어
좋은 지표임에도 불구하고 그러니까
연결 하는 그런 그 회사들이 많을
경우에 좀 외국이 생긴다고 보고 있고
그 그런 차원에서 이제 어 EPS로
보는게 저는 조금 더 어 우리나라
같은 경우는 좀 어 타당하다라고
생각을 하고 있는데
>> 어 모르겠습니다. 이게 보는 관점에
따라서 어 우리도 이제 그 어 증시나
어 경제 자체가 좀 선주형으로 어
가다 보면 또 미국 식으로 또
EPS가 얼마데? EPS에 몇 배에
지금 그 코스피가 거래되고 있다.
요런 식의 설명도 앞으로 늘어날 것
같은데 어 개인적으로는 그 평가
자체를 어 그렇게 하는 거는 저는
자연스러운 어 방향이라고 생각을
합니다.
>> 감사합니다. 아마 오랜버핏께서도
한국에서이 그 영업 이익이 그렇게 증
뭐라 그러죠? 고풀려진 부분이 있다는
걸 아셨으면
>> 어 약간 또 다르게 말씀하셨을 수도
있어요.
>> 예. 그렇습니다.
>> 예. 한국도 이렇게 조금씩 회계
기준이 바뀌고 미국하고 어 동일하게
비교할 수 있게끔 좀 개선이 되면 더
좋지 싶습니다. 국내 어 1년물 1년
전기예금 금리는 이제 시중 은행도
3% 이상 주는 곳들이 늘어날 정도로
>> 한국 금리가 상승 중은 아니지만 이미
시종 금리는 상당히 반영을 하기
시작한 거 같다는 생각도 지난 주말에
쭉 자료를 보면서 하게 됐습니다.
자, 오늘 여기까지 보면 될까요?
예, 그렇습니다.
>> 예, 꼼꼼히 좀 말씀해 주셔서 저도
옆에서 오늘도 도움 많이 받았습니다.
오늘 월요일 날 드리는 밸루에이션
그리고 주요국 전체적인 한국과 미국
증시 내용까지 말씀드렸고
어, 이제 2부에서 한국시장 바로
보면서 또 점 질문들은 부사장님에게
또 Q&A 해 주시지 않을까
싶습니다. 일부 오늘 좀 길었는데요.
함께 해 주신 채널 여러분 감사드리고
잠시 후 2부에서 다시 뵙겠습니다.
감사합니다. 감사합니다.
>> [음악]
>> เฮ
[음악]
>> 안녕하세요. 행복한 투자의 여정을
체슬리 투자 여자 여자분과 함께
체슬리 모닝 브리프 오늘 7월 6일
즐거운 월요일 2부 순서 시작하도록
하겠습니다.
늦장마인 거 같아요.
6월 달에 비가 안 오다가 7월 달
돼서
>> 비가 촉촉히 내렸다가 또 확
쏟아졌다가
>> 그렇죠.
>> 예.
아주 좋습니다.
제가 새 차를 거의 안 하거든요.
>> 예. 그래서 이렇게 비가와 주면 차를
일부러 밖에다 세워 놨는데
새 차도 되고 어제 또 오후에 죽고
하는데 또 한번 소나귀가 확
쏟아지니까
>> 시원하게
좋더라고요.
자이 사계절이 뚜렷하고음 비도 많이
오는 우리나라 축복된 축복받은 나라인
거 같습니다. 자, 지난주 금요일
한번 리뷰해 보도록 할 텐데이 별주
부전을 제가 아침에 오면서 다시 한번
들었어요.
>> 예.
>> 토요일 날 들어서 되게 좋았는데
최부자형님 또 나오셔 가지고
>> 예. 주옥 같은 코멘터 쭉 그 펀드
매니저 아 그 JP모관의
>> 가이트마켓 가이드투더마켓
>> 그 내용도 쭉 놔뒀고
>> 또 별주버전에서
한 주 요약을 쫙 해 주니까 어
그랬었지 하면서 아침에 오는데 또
약간 까먹은 거 같아서 한 번 더
별주 구전 들어오면서 왔었는데 자
국내 시장 어 과장이 수고를 해 주겠
해 주시겠습니다.
네. [목을 가다듬음] 금요일 시장
말씀드리겠습니다.
코스피 지수가 5.7% 좀 강한
반등세를 보이면서 올라왔고요.
코스닥은 보합 정도로 마감서
금요일장에서 시장이 오전장이 좀
내려오다가 좀 급격하게 반등하는
모습이 나타났었던 거 같고요.
수급적으로 봐 주시면 개인 투사자가
6조 넘게 매수세가 유입이 됐습니다.
반면에 외국인 투사자 4조 4,억
매도가 있습니다. 기관에서도 한 2조
가량 매도가 나왔었고 메인 선물에서는
3조 넘게 강한 매수세가 유입되기로
했습니다.
투자자별 매매 동향으로 가서 보면
외국인 투자자는 어 삼성전기, 대덕
전자, LG 이노텍, HPSP,
현대차, 현대 무비스 등을 매수를
하면서 최근에 많이 빠졌던 IT 기판
쪽에 대한 매수세가 좀 강했던 거
같고요. 외국인 매도에는 SK이닉스
1조 7천억 삼성전자 3,800억
가량 매도하면서 최근에 뭐 3조 4조
막 이렇게 매도하다가 매도 규모
자체는 좀 줄어드는 거 같고요. 그
외에는 주성 엔지니어링, SK
스퀘어, LS렉 이수페타, 효성
중고, HD 현대 일렉트릭 등을
매도했습니다. 기관 매수에는
SK하이닉스 2조 5,억 3조
삼성전자 1조 3천억 가량 매수를 좀
강하게 들어왔던 거 같고요. 그
외에는 KB 금융, 전자 우선주,
하나 에로스페이스, SK 스퀘어 등을
매수했습니다.
기관 매도에는 삼성전기, 대덕 전자,
LG, 이노택 등을 매도하면서
기관에서는 IT 기판 쪽 매도한
반면에 외국인에서는이 기판 쪽을 좀
더 중심적으로 매수했던 거 같습니다.
52주 신고가 종목은 총 세 종목밖에
안 나왔는데요. 코스피에서 한국 콜마
한 종목이 있었고요. 코스닥에서는
인테플러스 지오 엘리먼트 조종기
시국가였습니다.
예. 한국 콜마 보니까 별주부전에서
한국 콜마에 대해서 햄버거님이 쭉
커버를 해 주셔 가지고
어이 주관 단위로 크게 올라가는
주식들 모니터링은 보통 주식을 하다
보면 내가 갖고 있는 주식만 계속
쳐다보게 되고 다른 주식 올라올 때
안 보게 되거든.
안 보게 돼요.인지 편형적인 성향이
우리 몸에 되어져 있기 때문에.
그래서 별추전하면서 되게 좋더라고.
그 미국 기업 모드나 하고 또 하나
뭐였죠?
둘 중에
>> 뭐다 팔란티어였습니다.
>> 어 팔란티어 최분단이 둘 다 안 산다
[웃음]
>> 얘기했었고 그것 가지고 나중에
이런저런 토 토론하는 모습이 어 되게
보기 좋더라고요.
그래서 저도 보면서 이런저런 의견들음
아 지금 이런 주식들이 또 주관단위도
또 돌고 있구나 근데 그게 하락
추세에서 반짝 반등은 늘 있는
[목을 가다듬음] 거니까
>> 그런 반짝 반등인 건지
>> 모드나 같은 경우에는 보면 좀 의미
돌아서는 그런 모습이 된데
>> 모멘텀이
어떤 모멘텀이 생겨서 저렇게 주가가
올라가는지
그런 것도 알 수 있었고 한국 기업
중에서는 한국 콜마 그다음에 폼리어
같은
>> 화장품 쪽이
>> 어 쭉 벨주 보다 보니까 어 벌써
이렇게 많이 올랐나 싶더라고 그죠?
그래서 어 [콧방귀] 사실 6월 수출
데이터에서도 다 나왔잖아요. 반도체
1등이고. 네.
>> 그다음에 보니까 화장품도 상당히 어
수출이 잘 나왔었는데
어 말씀드린 것처럼 뭐 반도체가
200% 증가하다 보니까 다른 것들
뭐 2, 30% 증가하는게 눈에 안
보여서 그런데 갈로면 또 가고
있구나.
상당히 공부가 어제도 많이 됐습니다.
[목을 가다듬음]
근데 외국인은 하이닉스를
1조 7,550억 때린 거야. 이게
>> 왜 왜 이렇게 때리는 거예요? 계속
이번 주에 ADR 상향도 있잖아요.
>> 네. 네. 뭐 매도 규모 자체는
줄어들고 있기는 한데 여전히 좀 매도
모위는 나타나는 거 같고 저희고 항상
말해 왔던 그 삼성전자 SK닉스에
대한 포트폴리오에 내 비중이 너무
높아지고 있기 때문에 팔아도 팔아도
주가 상승이 더 강했잖아요.
>> 그런 매도가
>> 여전히 나오는게 아닌가 생각이
>> 지분율이 이제 50% 밑으로 떨어진
거 같은데.
>> 네. 만 예. 어 어디서 뭐
빈집이라고 얘기도 하더라. 외국인들
수급으로만 보면.이
>> 정도 때렸으면.
>> 네네.
>> 자 전자하고 하이닉스 외국인 매도가
좀 있었고 반면에 이제 기관은 전자
하이닉스를 또 공격적으로 샀습니다.
그죠?
자 주요 종목들 동량 한번
보겠습니다. 금요일 날 양봉 얘기
했었는데 강하게 올랐어요.
>> 이렇게 오를 줄 몰랐는데.
그러니까 요즘 지난번에도 그때도
똑같은 얘기 했었는데 장태 음목
나오고 그다음날 반발 매수 들어오다가
또 밀리는 그런 패턴이 그 얘기하고
그 그러고 나서 항상 양봉 다시
나더라고 오히려 오후장에 말아
올리면서 그죠 제 예상이 틀렸는데
한번 종국들 동명 한번 쭉
보겠습니다. 아마 이번 주에 삼성자
실접 발표가 예정이 되어 있고 7월
10날에는 SK하이닉스 ADR 상장
모멘텀이 앞에 있음에도 불구하고
주가가 많이 빠졌었기 때문에 좀
반등이 강했던게 아닌가라는 생각이
들고요. 반도체 섹터 먼저 봐 주시면
대형 반도체 쪽에 삼성전자가 8%
급세를 보여줬었고 SK닉스가 약
11% 큰 폭의 상승률을 기록을
했습니다. 반도체 소부장 쪽은 뭐
대체로 좋았었는데요. HPSP가
11% 가량 급등세를 보여줬고요.
리노 공업 4.6, 이오테크 2%
가량 상승 마감했습니다. 뭐 그 외에
아래 장비주들도 대체로 좋았고요.
특히 어 ISC가 모처럼 좀 8%
가량 반등세를 보였던게 특징적이었던
거 같고요. 또 하반기나 하반기에는
또 삼성자 파운드리에 대한 기대감이
좀 있을 수 있기 때문에 두산테스나
같은 기업도 최근에 좀 주목을 받는
거 같습니다.
IT 섹터에선 삼성 전기가 3% 가량
상승으로 마감했고요. LG 전자 LG
이노텍트때는 또 약세를 보이기도
했습니다. 아래 모바일 밸류 체인에
있는 VH나 파인 M텍은 또 강한
상사세를 보였고요. 하반기에 애플의
싱
어 아이폰이 출시될 예정이고 또
폴더블 관련된 폴드 관련된 아이폰도
출시될 예정이기 때문에 내장 인지하는
파인 MT텍 주가도 하반기에 좀
기대에 불법하지 않나는 생각이 좀
들고요. 플랫폼 섹터는 시장 대비로는
조금 부진한 흐름 보였습니다. 어
니케이 지수 1.5%가량 반등에
성공을 했는데 국내 시장보다는 좀
약했던 거 같아요. 엘 일렉트론 보합
정도의 상승률 기록을 했고 아래에
무라타가 1.9, 호야가 1.3
어드반 테스트가 1.8% 가량
상승하면서 그래도 반도체 장비나 기판
쪽이 나쁘지 않았습니다. 어 자동차
섹터도 조금이나마 반등을 했는데요.
현대차가 2%, 기아가 4.7, HL
만도 4% 가량 상승 마감했습니다.
현대차는 최근에 뭐 리프트들 보니까
차량 판매량이나 어 실적 측면에서 좀
괜찮을 거다라는 이야기가 많긴 한데
현대차 주가가 올라갔던 부분이
자동차로 올라간게 아니라서 지금 그런
부분이 주가에 반영이 되고 있지 않은
상황입니다. 어 소비 섹터로 봐
주시면 생검보와 마모래가 1.5%
오르면서 나모래가 이틀 연속 상승하는
모습이 나타났고요. 그래서 원머스
기준으로도
나쁘지 않습니다. 11% 가량 상승
중에 있고요. 코스메카 코리아는 한
2.5% 하락 마감했습니다. 아래
피부 미용 기계기 섹터는 원테일
제역은 대체로 약세였는데요.
클래파마 뭐 슈젤 AP 대처 한 3%
이상의 납품을 보였습니다. 어 그리고
아래 음식 섹터에서선 농심식품이
어 다시 좀 마이너스권으로
들어갔고요.
백화점 체임이나 면세도 안 좋았는데
신세계 현대 백화점 한 3%씩
끌렸습니다.
조선철미 기타 섹터 봐 주시면 2.2
하락한 반면에 하나 오션이 그래도
2.3%랑 상승으로 마감하는
모습이었고요.
철강이나 화학 섹터는 보합 정도의
등락이었고
아래에 방산주 쪽으로 내려가서 보면
한화 에어로가 5.3 승클 넥손이
5% 현대 로템이 1.6%가량
상승 마감하면서 방산주의 흐름이
나쁘지 않았습니다.
좀 특징적이었던 건 대용 반도체가
저렇게 쐈는데 그래도 타섹터도 좀
상승하는 종목들이 많았다는 점은 좀
최근 흐름과는 달랐던 거 같고요.
바이오섹터 봐 주시면
삼성 바이오가 1% 가량 상승
마감했고 셀트리온도 호실적 발표하고
주가가 상승 마감했습니다. 어 나머지
코스닥 바이오는 대체로 코스닥 시장
자체가 좀 약했다 보니 약세 흐름을
모였고요.
최근에 은행주가 굉장히 좋습니다.
KB 금융이 3%대 올라줬고 특히
지난주에 좀 많이 상승을 했던 거
같고요. 증권주들도 반등을 시작을
했는데 어 최근에 좀 많이 빠져서
밸류 메리트도 좀 강한 상승세를
금요일장에 보였었습니다.
엔터 쪽은 대체로 목요일까지
좋았었는데 금요일장에 좀 약세로
전환하는 모습이었고요. 변합기 섹터
한 2%대의 하락률을 기록을
했습니다.
>> 네. 근데이 전체적인 우주 종목도
동양 표를 보면서
지난주가 되게 전부 다이
썼는데
약간 또 희미하게나만 약간 어
붉은색이 살살 보이는 쪽이 소비제쪽
>> 네이
>> 살살 좀 밝아지고 있고요.
어 밑에도 보니까 조선 철광 화학
에너지 방산 항공 제약 바이오 금융
엔터 요쪽도 다시 좀 화내지는 약간
그런 느낌은음
자 주요 종목들 동양 받고요. 어
리포트 가져오셨는데
증권주의 역설 왜 이렇게 소외되는가
반등의 조건은 무엇인가 어 SK
장님임 연권 보트담
>> 저도 궁금하이에요. 진짜 왜 이렇게
소해야 되는지
>> 증권주들이 최근에 그래도 반등을 하고
있어서 좀 가져왔는데요. 높은
거래대금과 실적 하지만 소외된
주가라고 합니다. 유리없는 지수
상승과 1평균 거래대금은 100조원
시대임에도 증권 업종의 주가는 크게
부진을 했었는데요. 2011년 차화정
랠리와 마찬가지로 특정 주도주로의
수급이 집중되면서 증시 호조와
거래대금 급증에도 불구하고 정작권주는
소외되는 역설적인 현상이 나타나고
있다고 합니다. 어 2000년 이후
상승장에서는 수급 솔림을 제외하면
거래대금보다 증권주가 먼저 하락하는
사례는 좀 드물었었다라고
하고요. 거래 대금과 증권주의 동행
관계를 고려 했을 때 현재 1평균
거래 대금이 QQ 증가세라는 점에서
증권주가 선행적으로 크게 하락할 분면
아니라고 판단을 한다. 어 반도체
주도 장세에서 소외되는 것은 어찌할
수는 없겠지만 수납매가 나타나게
된다면 증권주의 관심을 한번 더
가져봐야 할 때가 아니냐라는
의견이고요. 결국 거래대금의 확산
여구가 증권주의 핵심 변수로 평에 좀
작용할 거 같다라는 의견입니다.
거래대금 픽아웃 우려도 최근 시장에
있는데요.
중건주에 요구하는 새로운 재료가
나와야 된다라고 하는데
어 시장에서 우려하는 거래대금 성장세
둔화 자체는 좀 불가피할 것으로
전망을 했는데 다만 픽아웃 우려를
상쇄할 수 있는 재료는 몇 가지가
있다라고 합니다. 어 첫 번째 ETF
성장인데요. 단일 종목 레버리지
ETF 출시 이후요 ETF 거래
대금이 더욱 빠르게 증가하고 있다라고
하고 주목할 점은 거래 대금만이
아니다라고 합니다. 단일 종목
레버리지 ETF 주시 이후 기존의
증권업에서 공고이 주시되던 점유율의
판도가 좀 바뀌고 있다라고 하고요.
DMA 서비스에 힘입어 한국 투자
증권의 ETF 점유율이 요래 크게
올라가면서 ETF를 포함한 브로코리지
점유에서 1위인 키움 증권과의 격차가
크게 축소가 됐다고 합니다. 6월
기준으로 키움이 14.8%고요.
한국 금융 지주가 13.6% %
점유율을 가지고 있다고 합니다. 어,
두 번째 하반기 정책 기대인데 회전율
및 거래대금 확대에 기여할 수 있는
정책들이 연내에 좀 예정이 되어
있다라고 하고요. 금융당국은 외국인
통합계좌의 투자 기능 대상을 아,
투제 투자 가능 대상을 국내 ETF로
확대하는 방안을 추진을 하고 있고
하반기의 코스닥 활성화 정책도
구체화될 예정이라고 합니다. 그래서
투자회견은 증권 업종에 대한 오버에를
유지를 했고요. 그중에서도 한국 금융
지주 삼성 증권을 최선호주로
꼽았습니다. 어 투자 전략으로는
브로커리지 부분을 기초 체력으로
가져가면서
유래 없는 주식 시장 강세 수회를
극대화할 수 있는 포트폴리오를 보호한
종목 중심으로 어 접근하는 것을
추천을 한다라고 하고요. 최선호주로는
한국 금융 지주 삼성권이 두 종목을
기존에도 어 타픽으로 꼽았었는데
이번에도 유지를 했고요. 어 주 종목
모두 브로커리 및 자산 관리 부분에
이익도가 높고 밸류 메리트까지 좀
있다. 이에 더해 한국 금융 지주는
주식 시장 강세로 자회사의 유가 증권
평가에 있기어도 어 가능하다는
얘기까지 했습니다.
[목을 가다듬음] 4례표로 내려가서
보면 어 거래대금과 코스피 지수 증권
주추위 결국 이건 다 동행했다라고
하는데요. 지금 시장에서 나오는 얘기
자체는이 증가가
좀 꺾일 가능성이 있다. 거래 대금
자체가. 근데 연구원님이 말씀하시는
거는 증가율 자체는 꺾이더라도이 금액
자체가 유지되거나 올라갈 가능성은
여전히 남아 있기 때문에 픽아웃
우려는 좀 시기상조 아니냐라는
의견이고요. 오른쪽은 유니버스 증권의
KRX NXT ETF 점유 합산인데
현재 키움 증권이 14.8%로 8%로
아직까지는 1위 기록 중에 있고요.
한투가 거기를 이제 발빠르게 쫓아오고
있는데 13.6% 6% 점유율을
차지하고 있습니다.
그리고 아래로 내려가서 아 옆에 표도
같이 봐 주시면 이거 장표로 보면 좀
더 이게 유의미하게 다가올 거 같은데
키움 증권의 점유율이 급격하게
빠졌는데요.
5월 달까지만 해도 키움 증권의
점유율이 25%였습니다.
근데 현재 15%까지
어 거의 한 8% 7% 포인트가
1개월 만에 훅 빠졌다라고 볼 수
있고요. ETF 쪽에서
유미한 성과가 한에서 좀 나타났다라고
볼 수가 있겠고 어 내려가서 보면
유니버스 증권 ETF 거래대금
점유율도 같이 나오는데요. 거래대금
자체가 지금 한 초가 26.7%로
7%로 1위를 차지하고 있고요. 그
외에는 NH 2위, 3위가 키움,
그다음이 미래 증권입니다.
어, 오른쪽 표로 보면 또 이게
명확하게 늘어나게 되는데 한투가 5월
달에
한 10% 중반 때 한 13% 정도
됐던 거 같아요. 근데 6월
들어오면서 한 27% 정도까지
거래대금 점유도 크게 올라왔는데
대체로 키움 증권의 점유를 많이
뺏어오는 흐름이지 않나는 생각이
들고요. 오른쪽은 유니버스 증권
12개월 포드 PB 밸루에이션
추인데요.
확실히 미래 증권은 스페이스 X 상장
모멘텀으로 주가를 급격하게 당겼다가
어 상장하고 하기 전부터 사실 좀
하락하기 시작을 했었고요. 모멘텀이
현실화되니 어 셀 온이 좀 미리
먼저부터 나오기 시작했고 최근까지 그
흐름이 이어지고 있었다 볼 수 있을
것 같고요. 밸루에이션 측면으로도
미래셋은
어 스페이스 X 상장 모멘텀 때문에
과거 증권사들이 높게 봤던
밸류에이션조차도
훨씬 뛰어넘는 PB 한 세배까지
올라갔었기 때문에 좀 더 주가 낙폭이
크게 나타났던 거 같고요. 나머지
종목들은 뭐 이전 PB수 대비 높게는
거래됐다고 하지만 뭐 그 레벨 자체가
그닥 높진 않았기 때문에 상대적으로
좀 양공했던 것 같습니다.
그 아래는 제가 그 첫 번째 보라색이
키움이고요. 노란색이 한국 금융 취주
하늘색이 삼성 증권의 PBR
밸류에이션 추인데요.
삼성 증권이 최근에 좀 많이 올라오다
보니까 키움 증권의 밸루에이션을
초월했더라고요. 그래서 지금이 세
계사 중에서는 어 삼성 증권이
1.1배로 포드 PBR 배수론 가장
높게 거래가 되고 있고요. 그다음에
키움 증권이 한 1배 그리고 한국
금융 지수가 노란색인데 0.9배 9배
정도의 거래되고 있습니다. 지금
사실이 업항이나 점유율측면에서
매력도를 따져 보면 사실 삼승 아 그
키움 증권보다는 한국 금융 지수가 더
높은 밸류로 갈 수 있지 않을까라는
생각이 조금 들기는 했습니다.이 표를
보면서.
음.
그렇네요. 보니까. 음. 근데 이게
전체 거래대금에
의한 점유일하고
ETF가 어떻게 한투 쪽으로 유니버스
증권 ETF 거래대금 점유율이 6월
기준으로 한투가 26.7%
희한하죠.
>> 네.
>> 한투가 에이스였던
거 같겠죠.
키 그거는
>> 한국
그 한투 자전 운용이
>> 그걸 운용하는 거고 이거는 증권에서
거래되는 모든
>> ETF 거래대금 점유율이잖아.
>> 예. 그렇습니다.
>> 음.
그 코덱스는 삼성자 운영이고.
>> 네.
>> 근데 지금 그게 ETF 점유율이
아니라 ETF 거래대금 점유율이거든.
그래서 이거는 한투 증권을 이용하고
계신
어 고객분들이 특별히
ETF 매매를 좀 많이 한다고 그렇게
해 봐요. 거 같은데.
>> 예. 그 액면상으로론 그렇습니다.
예.
>> 그 한토에서 뭐 DMA 시스템을
도입을 했다라고 하는데
>> 그게 뭐예요?
저도 처음 들어보는 용어라서
찾아보니까 이게 HTS나 MTS를
거치지 않고 고객의 주인 거래소로
바로 연결되는 좋은 방식이라고
하더라고요. 그래서 초단타 매매하시는
분들이나 알고리즘 매매, 프로그램
매매하시는 분들에게
>> 되게 유의미한 프로그램이라고 하는데
이걸 한초가 최근에 도입했다고 해요.
>> 그래서
>> ETF 레버리지 ETF들도 많이
상장됐겠다. 시장 변동성도 커졌겠다.
그러다 보니 초단타 매매하시는 분들이
제가 알기로 키움 증권을 많이 쓰시는
걸로 알고 그
>> 점유율이 좀 한두 쪽으로 넘어온게
아닐까
>> 그런 생각이 좀 수도 있겠는데
>> 청구 매니저 그런 거 들어온 적
있어요?
>> 제가 봤을 때는 그것보다도 그 인터넷
증권사들 있잖아요. 토스뱅크나 이런
쪽들이 크게 올라오면서 그 제가 지금
자료를 보이는데 25%가 점유율이
깨졌거든요. 킴 증권이. 근데 제가
한참 키운 친구가 봤을 때 한
30%에서 40%도 갔었던 적이
있었던 걸로 알고 있는데 어 여러
가지 이유가 있긴 하겠지만 투수
증권총이 올라온게 좀 크다라고 저는
봤었었습니다. 네.
근데이 DMA 서비스라는게
그러니까 두 배짜리 ETF 요런 거
매매하기 좋게
그런 거는 있긴 있거든요. 저희가
기관 매매할 때 예전에 제가 파생
매매 한참할 때음 어디가 조금 더
빠르다. 그게 0점 뭐 거의 1초
차이도 아니고 0. 뭐 몇 초 차이.
음.
>> 그러니까 요게 체결이 조금 더 빨라
빠르다고 이런 곳이 있긴 했었는데
약간 그런 개념인가 보다. 그죠?
DMA으로
좀 더 빨리
수 있게
그런 거 같은데요
부분은 어 좀 더 알아보고 내일
말씀드리도록 하고
그래서 지금이 당연 얘기는 2000년
이후 상승장에서 수급 솔림을 제외하면
거래대금보다
증권주가 먼저 하락한 사례는 없었고
거래대금과 증권제 동행관 관계로시에는
지금 현재 1평균 거래대금이 Q
증가세라는 점에서는이
증권주가 이렇게 빠질 국면은 아니다는
거죠.
반도체 주도 장세에서 소해되는 것은
어쩔 수 없지만 수남매가 나타난다면
정권주에 한 번 더 관심을 가져봐도
될 거 같아.
그런 얘기고 밑에
새로운 자료 중에 하나가 ETF 성자
그다음에 하반기 정책 기회 이런
식으로 돼 있고 어 선호하는
종목으로는 한국 금융지죠 삼성권
요렇게 얘기를 해 줬습니다. 그리고
밑에이 표도 나오지만이 미래 세 증권
지금 반토막거든.
점 대비 - 50% 이상.
>> 어 왜 그런가요? 하시는 분들도
계셨는데 지금이 PBR 주의를 보면
뭐 증권이 그렇게 뭐 차별화되지가
않기 때문에 미래나 한투나 삼성이나
NH나
그래서 거의 뭐 PBR이
근처에서 왔다 갔다 하면서 움직이는
주식인데
미래가 스페이스엑스 상장 때문에 딱
보니까 지나측에만이 PBR이 거의
세배 정도까지 갔습니다.
>> 네.
거기에 다른이 이벤트 지리번으로 하던
해치펀드 같은 점수들이요
스페이스엑스 상장할 때쯤 돼서 매도
때리면서 이익 실현하고 나오는
모습이다. 그죠? 그러면서 다시 어
좀 많이 빠져서 뭐 좀 사불만하지
않나 생각했었는데 지금 아직까지도
피어 그룹 대비해서 PBR이네.
같습니다. 프리미엄은 좀
>> 어 그래서 너무 고점 대비 많이
빠졌다라고만 생각하지 마시고 예이
피어 그룹하고 결국은 붙을 걸로
생각이 되는데
조금 더 봐야 되겠다. 그죠?
>> 네.
자, 그다음 리포트는 메모리 패키지
기판 업종 매수 권고 하나 김민경
연구원 자료
>> 최근에 뭐 기사화로 많이 나오긴
했었는데 [목을 가다듬음] 기판 판가
인하의 압박이 좀 메모리 업체들한테서
있었다고 하더라고요. 그래서 그
내용을 리포트로 작성을 해 준 거
같은데요. 메모리 패키지 기판 판가
인하 우려는 기우라고 판단을 하고
있는데요. 메타 컴퓨팅 자원 외부임대
소식으로 AI 버블 우려가 확대가
됐고 하반기 메모리 패키지 기판 판가
인화 가능성까지 제기되면서 대덕
전자나 심택 해성s 등 메모리 패키지
기판 업체대 주가가 큰 조정을
지난주에 좀 받았던 바 있습니다.
어 다만 26년 하반기 패키지 기판
수급 무려가 커지는 상황에서 높은
이익률을 기록 중인 메모리 IDM들이
폐기시기판 가격을인할 요인은 어좀
제한적이라고 보고 있고요. 이번 주가
조정은 오히려 강한 매수 기회로 볼
필요가 있겠다. 그래서 오히려 공급
부적 우려가 확대가 되고 있는
상황인데요. 26년 4월 메모리
패키지 기파는 금이나 불이든 원재료
가격 상승을 반영해서 전반적인 한가
인상이 이루어질 바 있습니다. 단순
원가 상승뿐만 아니라 하반기 수급
타이트 가능성도 일부 반영된 인상으로
추정이 된다라고 하고요. 메모리
패키지 기판업체들의 생상 능력은
20년에서 22년 대규모 증설이후
사실상 정체된 사항이라고 합니다.
당시 주력 제품은 DDR4랑 LP
DDR 4였는데
현재는 DDR5, LP DDDR5
그리고 5X 쪽으로 중심으로 전환이
되면서 기판 대면적화 고다층화가 진행
되면서 실질 케파 자체는 감소하고
있다라고 합니다. 마치 그 메모리
업체들이 HPM 쪽으로 어 케파를
많이 활용을 하면서 실제 케파 실제
웨이퍼 생산량으로 줄어든 것과 같은
맥락이라고 봐 주시면 될 거 같고요.
메모리 고성능화와 다이 사이즈 확대가
케파 잠식을 가속화하고 있다라고
하고요. 대만의 유니마이크론이나
그리고 삼상전기 등 상위 업체들은
수익성 높은 플래치 BJ 쪽으로
증서에 집중을 하고 있기 때문에
글로벌 BT 기판 업 공급 여력은
더욱더 좀 제한적인 상황이다. 26년
하반기에는 NBDR 루빈양 일반
메모리 공격 확대와 중국 메모리
업체들의 DDR 5 추화 확대가
예정이 되어 있다라고 하고요.
중장기적으로 메모리 3, 공격적인
증설이 이어질 것으로 예상이 되고
메모리 패키지 기판 수요는 지속적으로
증가할 가능성이 높다라는 의견입니다.
그래서 메모리 패키지 기판 역시 공급
부족 가능성이 높아질고 있다는
판단이고요. 쇼티지 시그널은 LTA로
볼 수가 있겠는데
어 패키지 기판 쇼티지 여은 LTA
체결 여부가 가장 중요한 시그널로
보고 있다고 하고요. 20년 3월
심택은 마이크로양 1억 이상의 대규부
공급 계약을 체결한 바 있었다라고
하고 메모리 패키지 기판은 납기가
짧은 산업 특성상 이례적인 규모의
계약이었다라고 하고요. 이후 실제
공급 부족이 심화되고 가격 인상
사이클이 본격화 됐었다고 합니다.
현재 글로벌 기판 수급 상황을 감안해
보면 26년 하반기에도 유산 흐름이
나타날 수 있겠다라는 의견이고요.
이번 메모리 패키지 기판 업체들의
주가 조정은 중장기적으로 매수 기회로
활용할 필요가 있겠다 겠습니다.
최근에 대덕이나 뭐 심택 해성 DS
이런 종목들 낙폭이 단기적으로 좀
크게 나타나긴 했었는데요. 워먼스
기준으로 대덕이 한 17% 이수페타가
20%
크게 하락했습니다. 심텍은 어
상대적으로 좀 경고하고
경고하더라고요. 목요일에는 급락하긴
했었는데 원먼스 기준으로 보면 한
23%가
상승 중에 있기 때문에
기판 업체들 중에서는 지금 뭐
대덕전자 같은 기업이 밸류 메리트가
좀 올라와 있는 상황이지 않나라는
생각이 들고요. 아래는 심택 수수
장고 추위랑 어 대덕 전자 수주 장고
추위가 나오고 있는데 확실히 플리치
BJ 쪽이 쇼티지가 먼저 지금
나타나고 있잖아요. 그러다 보니
플리치 비하고 있는 대덕 전자 쪽의
수주 장가 더 빠르게 차오르고 있는
상황이다 볼 수 있을 것 같고요.
심택은 사실 여기에 추가로 볼 수
있는 모멘텀은 소캠이기 때문에 그
부분은 수장고에 아직은 좀 높아져
있지 않다라고 볼 수가 있겠고요.
오른쪽은 심택 실적 추위와 대덕
전자의 실적 추위인데 여기도
마찬가지지만 확실히 고부가 하는 쪽이
항상 더 회복이 빠릅니다. 대덕
전자가 오른쪽인데요.
지금 어 1분기 실적 기준으로 높이
마지반대
수준까지 빠르게 올라온 상황이고요.
심택의 경우는 한 3%대 정도의 오피
마진을 기록 중에 있기 때문에
아직까지 레오시기판 쪽으로의 공기는
퍼지지 않았다. 완전히 퍼지진 않은
거 같고 연구이 말씀하시는 거는
심택이 과거 쇼티지 상황에 LTA
계약까지 마이크론과 체결을 했었는데
그런 상황이 있고 난 이후에 가격
인상이 가파르게 나타났었다라고
하더라고요. 이렇게 되면 저기 뒤에
보이는 22년 경에 심택의 마진이
거의 20%까지 그 이상까지 취소
샀는데 그런 수준을 기대 하기는 좀
레거시 기판이 지금 어 프리시처럼
쇼티 아니기 때문에 그런 부분까지
모르겠지만 마중이 한 그래도 10%
중반대까지 올라갈 가능성을 열어놔야
될 거 같고요. 대덕 전자는 오히려
과거 사이클이 22년 OP 마신을
넘을 가능성이 좀 높아진 상황이죠.
플래시 BJ 쪽으로 사업을 다 많이
바꿔 놨고 MLB도 지금 투자를 하고
있기 때문에 그래서 그런 관점으로
대속전자가 좀 더 좋아 보이기도 하고
각각의 모멘텀은 좀 다른 거
같습니다.
자, 지금이 밑에 있는 표랑 택
주가랑 제가 비교하면서이 좀 보고
있었는데
그 우리는 뭐 주식 투자하는 사람이다
보니까 그래서 실적자를 움직이는 건지
아니면 뭐 수주 따라서 움직이는 건지
이렇게 보고 있는데 침택 수주 장고
추위랑 축가 추위랑 거의 뭐 똑같네
보니까 변곡점이나 이런 부분은 그리고
2020년요 3월에 심택이 마이크로냥
1천억 이상 대규모 공급 계약 체결한
바 있다라고 해서 근데 2020년
3월이 뭐 코로나 때문에 완전히
전 세계가 이래 전히 봉쇄되 있는
그런 상황이었는데도
>> 오죽 다 급해서 이걸 체결했나씨
그런 생각도 들고 진짜 체결한게 맞나
싶은데요
왼쪽 도표 3 심택 수주 장고 추위
보니까요 코로나 때 2020년요 1큐
2 지나면서 수조 장고가 확 올라오는
거 보니까 어제 체결한 건 맞는 거
같긴 해요. 보니까 그죠. 그러고
나서 수주장고가 22년 초까지 쭉
늘어나는 모습이었는데 주가가 딱
22년
3월에 고점네요.
>> 네.
22년 3월에 고점 졌고 그러놓고
나서 수주고 추위 쭉 빠지는 거와
함께 거의 똑같이 빠졌네요. 니까
24년 초에 또 수주 장고 살짝 한번
위로 칠 때
23년 말부터 4년 초까지 살짝 반등
반등 정도로 약한 반등 들어갔다가
나중에 24년 하반기에 뭐 박살났네
주가가
57,000원 한 58,000원 하던
만 원 대까지 빠져 빠졌네. 그
80% 빠져요. 주가가
>> 적자로 확 들어가면서
>> 아 적자 들어가면서
>> 빠졌다가 최근에 수주 장고 추위이
늘어나는 거와 함께 주가가 파르게
올라왔는데 지난 22년 고점을 훌러등
지금 넘어선 상황이거든요.
자 고점 대비 164,200원
대비해서 고점 내에서 21% 지금
빠져 있네. 네.
침택은 오과장님 바닥에서 돌 때 제일
먼저 얘기했었죠.
그렇긴 한데요.
>> 네.
>> 이렇게 셀 줄도 몰랐고. 근데
소캠이라는게
유미하게 이렇게 주가에 반영이 될 줄
>> 잘 몰랐었기 때문에.
>> 네.
>> 그때 그러니까 반등 딱 시작할 때 그
얘기 했었거든. 네. 그리고
어 제 지인이 그 심태가고 아주
친하고 저도 예전에 심태
지금 사장님을 예전에 한번 만나본
적이 있긴 했었는데 그게 벌써 10
15년 전에 거
그래서 소켓에다 투자를
왕창해 놨는데 그 시장이 안 열리고
있다가 이번에 딱 그 시장이 열려서
서 어 케파 소캠에 대한 선투자리
이제 빛을 보고 있다. 예. 그
얘기를 하긴 하더라고요.
그게 뭐 소캠원이
엔비디아에서 스킵해 버렸잖아요. 소
2로 바로 넘어가면서 아마 작년에
나왔던 건 소켓 1원부터 들어가니까
우리 상반기부터 소캠시를 유미하게
찍힐 거 같다라고 했었는데 이렇게
밀렸거든요. 음. 그 부분이 이제
올해 하반기 내년 가면서 베라루비는
이제 탑대될 예정이기 때문에 그런
부분. 근데 그게 또 심택한테 되게
위미했던 건 레거시만 하던 회사가
그리고 다른 회사들은 레거시 하던
회사들이 플리치 피제로 넘어가면서
대덕 전자 같은 회사가 밸류가 높게
갔고 실적도 업항조게 갔었는데 그런
시도를 안 하던 회사가 하니까 약간
밸류 리레이리팅이
>> 음
>> 나타났던게 이번 심택 주가 상승의
주요 원동력이 아니었나라는
생각이 [콧방귀] 좀
그러면 여기 보면 수주 장고가 가
올해하고
내년에 계속 올라가요.
>> 근데 올라갈 수밖에 없는 지금
흐름으로 진입 하지 않았나라는
>> 생각이 들고 저번에도 저희끼리 말한
거지만 메모리보다 후행적으로 실적이
좋고 후행적으로 주가도 빠지잖아요.
그런 관점으로 보면 기판이 지금
끝났다라고 보기는 [콧방귀] 다소
어렵지 않나 생각.
>> 대적 전자도 보니까 고점 대비 35%
빠졌네.
>> 네. 월봉상에 5개월 2평까지 받았고
어 결국은 과거 주가 사례 보니까이
수주 장고 추위랑 플러스 실적
추위이랑 거의 거의 동행하면서 주가가
빠지게 되는데
어 아직까지 올해 내년 실적 증가세가
더 유지될 수밖에 없다는 거죠.
>> 네. 아직 그리고 가격 인상도 많이
나타나지 않은 상황인데 가격 인상까지
나타나면 저희가이 오피 마진 과거
추위 볼 수 있다시피 지금 올라온 건
사실 가동률 올라온 정도 먹고 있는
거거든.
>> 어
>> 이제 가격 인상 나오면 오피마진이
확대될 가능성이 높아진 거죠.
>> 음
>> 잘 봐야 되겠네.
단지 과거에 조정을 받을 때 하도
요쪽은 조정받으면
어 정말 아 이제이 정도면
충분히 조정받은 거 아닌가 해도
그죠.
>> 꼭 지하 2층 3층 뭐 5층까지
갔다가 올라오는 경량이 있어 가지고
변동성이 어느 정도에서
조정이 멈추는지 요런 거 좀 잘 보고
주자해야 될 것 같아씨.
[목을 가다듬음]
여기도 롱텀
계약이 있었다. 그죠?요 부분이
중요한 시그널이 될 거 같은데 올해
그럴 가능성이 하반기에 나타날
가능성이 높다.
>> 네.
알겠습니다. 잘 보겠습니다.
자, 국내 시장까지 앞에서 미리 미국
시장까지 다 해 놓으니까 시간적
여유가 좀 됩니다.
자, 예상 시가는 어느 정도 나오고
있습니까?
>> 예, + 1.45% 상승할 것으로
예상되고 있습니다.
>> 자, 미국 시장은 오늘 밤에는
이제 열리죠. 다시
>> 어 하루반 쉬고 다시 올라오는데
>> 과거 컨트적으로 분석을 해 보면 그
독립기념이 휴장하고 나서 미국 실행은
어땠나 모르겠네. 근데 7월이
나쁘지는 않았어요.
>> 아
>> 달 기준으로
>> 달 기준으로 나쁘지 않았는데
>> 자 내일 아침에는 누가 그 우리
유리프로가 없어서 약간 좀 허전하긴
한데
>> 내일 아침부터는 누가 미국 시장
거부합니까? 우리 장창민 프로가
담당을 했습니다.
>> 아, 장창민 프로가
>> 예,
>> 담당을 해 주시겠습니다.
>> 그러면 장장민 프로한테 오늘 밤 미국
시장 물어보면 되겠네.
>> 예, 그렇습니다.
>> 어, 장민프로 오늘 밤 미국 시장
어떻게 될 거 같아요?
오늘 밤 그 저번 주에 메타로 인해서
K픽스 공급 과잉이 아닌가 우려가
있었는데 그로 인해서 좀 반도체
시장이 좀 과도하게 좀 하락하는
추세를 보였거든요. 네. 금리가
인상되는 것에 대한 우려도 좀 완화된
모습도 보이고 있고 그 좀 구형
용량의 재배치 과정이라는 의견도
있어서 기술주의 전반적인 상승으로
SMP 500 받았어. 둘 다 상승
예.
둘 다 오늘 밤 상승할 것으로
예상한다. 그러고 창민 프로고 함께
제가 그때 밤새면서 일요일 날 와
가지고 자료 만들다 보니까 또 추천도
한 4시 50분쯤 출근권을 같이 하는
거 같은데 추천프가 그러면 다우
앞으로 해 볼까요? 추천프로는
[목을 가다듬음] 오늘 밤 미국 시장
어떻게 될 거 같아요? 뭐 다우든
SP 500이든 나스닥이든
>> 저도 오늘
미국 시장은 전반적으로 상승을 할 수
있을 거라고 제가 지난주에 좀
과도하게 기술들이 빠졌다고 생각을
해서
좋은 흐름이 이제 좀 나와주지
않을까?
>> 자, 나스닥이 이번 주하고 다음 주
되게 좀 중요한 부분이
>> 음.
>> 어. 나스닥이 지금 고점을 돌파를 못
하고 있잖아요. 그죠?
그런데 필반 지수는 고점 돌파하고
돌을 돌파했다가 내려왔었고
>> 예, 그렇습니다.
>> 그다음에 최근에 현상이 다우가
강해요. 나우가 나우는 지금
신고가를 내면서 올라가고 있고 요런
모습이 어 되게 중요한 부분이 22년
딱 조정장 오기 전에 21년 말에
비슷한 현상이 일어났었거든요.
그래서 21년 말에 필반 지수가
고점을 돌파하는데 나스닥은 12월
달에 11월에 고점을 돌파 못하고 좀
빌거리는 모습이 나왔었고 22년 1월
달에 다우부터
장중 고점이 나오거든요. 다우
포함식이 SP 500에도 있다 보니까
SP 500도 아마 그때 22년
1월에 고점이 나왔습니다.
>> 예. 아스닥만 그때
못 올라가는 모습이 나왔었는데
그래서 이번 달에 어 나스닥이 강하게
정보을 돌파를 해 줘야 돼요.
근데 긍정적인 거는 지금
마이크로소프트도 그렇고
어 소위 말하는 이제 빅테크들이 약간
꿈틀꿈틀
>> 예 머리도 드는 모습이 좀 나와
가지고요
>> 빅테크들이 돌아서는 모습이 나오면
그러면 나스닥이 이번 달에 정고점을
돌파할 수도 있지 않을까 그런 모습
그런 걸 이제 기대를 하기로 하는데
어, 시장이 어떻게 반응을 하는지이
좀 잘 보게 봐야 될 것 같습니다.
>> 예.
필반 지수는 오늘 밤 어떻게 될 것
같습니다. 상승입니다. 예.
일단 금요일 날 샘성자 SK하이닉스가
상당히 큰 폭으로 올랐던 부분이이
시장이 휴장이면서 어 반영을 못 했기
때문에 분명히 이제 그 부분이 반영될
거고 또 삼성전자 실적을 어느 정도
어 그 미국 시장 필반 지수에서 더
좀 기대를 하면서 수 있는 부분이
있기 때문에 예방
상승으로 하겠습니다. 예. 금요일 날
안 열렸었으니까 그죠.
>> 예.
>> 오히려 미국 시장이 우리 시장을 부
반영하면서
>> 예.
>> 그러니까 오늘이 반등이 좀 들어가야
되는 자리다. 그죠?
>> 예. 제가 볼 때는 한 5% 내외
오르지 않을까 싶습니다.
>> 일반 지수도예. 그러니까요. 그 정도
올라야만
초기가 이제 되는 거 같고.
>> 예. 맞습니다.
>> 필반 지수도 이번 달이 되게
중요합니다.
>> 예.
아까 나스닥이 선거점을 만약에 이번
달에 돌파로 추락해 간다면 뭐 필반이
또 변탁은 높기 때문에
>> 예
>> 강하게 올라가 줘야 되고
>> 그게 이번 주의 그런 모습이
>> 예
>> 장태 양복이 좀 나오는 모습이 나와야
분위기 전환하는 모습
>> 연출되지 않을까 예 그런
생각이습니다.
그래서 어 빌반하고 미국 시장은
오늘밤
상승으로 빠
그리고 지난번에 이역부장님이 적어
주셨지만
어 6월 달에 미국 시장이 고점 친
경우는 1950년 이후로 한 번도
없었다.
>> 그 그런 얘기가
>> 상당히 도움이 돼요.
>> 그렇습니다.
>> 어 그러고 보니까 그랬네.
그리고 9월 시장이 좀 안 좋은
이유가
항상 7월 시장이 좀 강하다 보니까
7월에서 8월 초까지 좀 당겨 놓고
그래서 9월이 또 약한 이유도
있었거든요.
>> 그 부분도 있고 단지 그 이세
이사님이신가요?
시티에 이세수열 이사님이 지난주
금요일인가이
>> 또 환경 나오셔 가지고 아주 진솔하게
또 어 인터뷰를 한
>> 음
>> 영상을 봤었는데
>> 이사철 이사님도 그 얘기를
하더라고요. 아, 전통적으로이
반도체가 또 7월 8일을 좀 약했던
경우가 있어서
>> 예, 좀 조정을 받는
>> 그런 모습도 나올 수는 있지만 하면서
그 아직까지도 의회 야구로 따지면
이외 이회다.
>> 뭐 이런 말씀을 하셨고
>> 그 보면서 굉장히 도움이 됐었는데
앞으로 향후 7년
>> 예, 그러시더라고요. 예,
>> 그죠? 아직 한 7년 더 남았다.
>> 예.
>> 어, 그 얘기라고
>> 그래서 어, 조금 큰 그림이 잡혀지.
자, 그래서 오히려 그런 말씀들
[목을 가다듬음]
따져 보면 어, 이번 달에는 원래는
이제 필반이 제일 강하게 치고 가야
되는데
>> 음. 어 이세설 이사님도 다 저는
계절성까지도 다 얘기를 다 보고
계시구나.
그래서 7월이 만약에 반도체가 약간
그런 단기적인 순고립이 좀 쉬
쉬어지는 모습이 7월 8월 나오면
그러면 아까이
지금 다른 섹터들 막 머리 드는
섹터들
>> 아우 반도체 형님 좀 쉬실 때 나도
좀 가자 뭐야 약간 이런 분위기
>> 그러니까
>> 이번 한 달 연출될 수도 있겠다. 어
그런 생각이 들더라고
>> 자 국내 시장 어떻게 됐습니까? 네.
시작했고요. 어, + 1.2%로 어,
상승해서 출발을 했고요. 현재는 +
0.61%로 소폭 하락하고 있습니다.
예, 8,186에서
8,130
지금 기록을 하고 있고 코스닥은
어떻게 되고 있습?
>> 네, 코스닥 -0.23%로
하락해서 출발했고요. 어, 현재는
-1.3%로
%로 하락 보을 좀 더 키우고
있습니다.
>> 이러면 또 우리 왕박사가 또 코스닥
음봉
>> 네봉은 나왔습니다.
>> 어 코스닥는 음봉
코스피는 어떻게 될 거 같
올라서 지금 시작하자마 차익 실현이
많이 나오긴
>> 하는데요. 지금 나스닥 선물이 그다한
1.5% 5% 4% 정도
그러더라고요.
>> 그러겠죠.
>> 오늘
양봉 가능성이 좀 더 높을 것
같습니다. 지금 뭐 1% 이상으로
항상 시작했다가 0.2%밖에 2%밖에
안 오긴 하는데 양 가능성이 좀 더
높다. 그 오전장에 매도 받아내고 또
올라갈 가능성이 있다라는 생각이
확실하게 오화장이 일봉 맞추는 거는
나보다 낫더라고.
어 내가 사실 그 일봉에 일각이
있었었는데 옛날에 선물 매매를 하다
보니까 요즘 선물 매매 안 한지도 좀
됐고 시장에 색깔이 좀 바뀌었나 그런
생각도 들고
그래서 이번 오늘은
>> 양봉
>> 그니까 지난주 금요일 날도
금요일인데도 양봉했는데 양봉 뭐죠?
하단은 친 거 같아요. 그
>> 네. 금요일에
>> 어 올린저 하단 살짝 뚫고 내려갔다가
바로 그냥 매수 들어오면서
올리더라고요.
>> 저번에 3월 전쟁 때도 딱 볼린 차
하단에서 하락이 멈췄었는데
>> 비슷한데
>> 그
그 댓글에서 누가 그렇게
얘기했더라고. 신기한 차트 분석
전문님 혹시 못 하실 때는 오가장에
올린저 밴드 좀 올려 달라고
>> 야 정말 좋은 댓글이시다. 어 내가
>> 그래서 그지
>> 아저도 정말 듣고 싶습니다. 그러니까
아니 내 거는 이제 나 월관 전망도
그 안 하고 싶더라고. 그래서 월관
전망은 왕이사가 하고 신기한 차트
분석 이런 거는 오과정이 하고
>> 은퇴해야 되겠더라고.
>> 아
>> 그래서 진짜 오후에 그 내가 출장
간다든지 외부 설명에 간다든지 하면
네. 오과장의 신기한 차트 보죠.
오신나. 오신나. 어 그렇지.
>> 오신나.
>> 어 오신나 한번 하자고.
아 그거 오신나가
더 인기를 돌 것 같아. 약간 불가한
불불기란 [웃음] 얘가
>> 어 그 댓글로지지 많이 해 주시기
바라겠습니다.
>> 뭐 벌써 오시나 막 그러니까 이꿈님도
좋아하시고 열평님 다 좋아하시네
보니까.
아 참
>> 저는 따로 막 기술적 분석을 공부해
보진 않아서 그냥 감으로 하는 편인데
>> 아니 [목을 가다듬음] 그러니까 난
가무 하는 줄 알았는데 볼린저 밴드를
얘기하면서 금요일 같은 시장이라든지이
다 맞추고 있잖아요. 이거 일봉 이거
하루짜리 맞추는게 얼마나 어려운데.
어, 나 이거 지금처럼 만약에 57%
이상 확률이 유지되잖아. 네.
>> 그러면 사실 선물 매매 이걸로 하면
돼.
>> 그렇잖아.
>> 아니, 확률이 50%가 훨씬 넘는데
그죠.
>> 그러면 계속 무한 반복하면 돈이
기약급적으로
늘어나거든.
[웃음]
뭐 나 그럴 거야. 나 은퇴하고 그냥
오거장 아침에 뭐라고 얘기하나?
양봉이라 얘기하나? 음봉이라
얘기하나? 그거 듣고 아침에 양봉
얘기하면 아침 시초가에 선물 매수.
>> 어 종가에 매도
[웃음]
>> 난 그거 하고 살 거야.
아, 참이 폭발적인 반응나
기대합니다.
오도령이 그냥 오도령이 된 거
아니잖아요.
>> 하도 잘 맞춰서 오도령이 됐는데.
>> 아우, 지금 뭐 거의
많은 분들이 네. 오가장님 해
주세요.
>> 어 벌써 양봉입니다.
>> 아 벌써 또 양봉으로잖아요. 그래서
>> 야 대단하다.
[웃음]
>> 대단하다.
>> 그러면 이게 응용을 할 수가 있는 게
>> 시초가 오과장이 만약에 양봉했잖아요.
>> 근데 지금 1.2 시초가에 일단
>> 절반 매수 들어가고 아까 0.8까지
더 밀리잖아. 그러면 이제 추가 매수
처음에 [목을 가다듬음] 들어가
가지고
>> 딱 오늘 양봉으로이 끝나면 야
월론부패보다 돈 더 벌 수 있을 것
같은데
>> 선물 한 개 얼마니까 요즘
>> 나도 요즘 안 해봐 가지고 선물
한계이 요즘 엄청 비싸
>> 그러니까 옛날에 뭐 아 뭐 300
200 뭐 100 이러다가
>> 그러니까요
>> 얼마야
그러니까요.
>> 원장님이 신기한 치다 거 같
>> 그지?
>> 왜냐면은
>> 그 가끔 가다가 전문님 성대사를 해
주시거든요.
>> 성대모사까지. 네. [웃음] 어디
옥상에서
아 옥상에서 뭐 업대 파츠 할 때네
>> 왔습니다. [웃음]
>> 웃낄 것 같습니다.
>> 어
오장의 재능은 도대체 어디까지?
청경모까지 가능하단 말이죠. 아,
네. 다 합니다. 뭐 왕사님,
>> 부사장님, [목을 가다듬음]
>> 사장님이 그 영상 시작할 때 항상
하시는 얘기어.
>> 네. 체입니다. [웃음]
>> 어, 뭐 기업 분석 이런 거 할 때도
그렇게 해. 그럴 때는 안 하고.
>> 근데 막상 카메라가 비춰지면은 약간
>> 또 약간
>> 네. 마스크를 좀 쓰시는 시크한
척하고. 네, 맞습니다.
>> 예. 아, 저기 선물 한 계약이 3억
2,900만 원 정도
>> 3억.
>> 예.
>> 1,316포인트
>> 기준으로 해서 25만 원. 어,
>> 맞아요. 그 정도 될 거예요.
>> 그래서 제가 그 신차 분석할 때
외국인 선물 거기는 대신에는 이제
계약수로 나와 가지고
>> 예.
>> 요즘은 계약수 곱하기 3 해
버리거든.
>> 예. 예.
아우
>> 어떻게 이렇게 빠나?
>> 우리 체슬리 TV에서 보면이 아침에
모닝 브리프도 그렇고 워맨 신박도
그렇고 그다음에 별주 부전 이렇게
히트 상품이 계속 터지는데 드디어
신나 또 나왔네요. 나왔어.
활색조 오도령님
>> 기대됩니다. 금
>> 아 진짜 기대됩니다. 난 최부장이
이렇게 기술적 분석에 이렇게 많은
기대감을 닦아내는 처음 보고
>> 가잖아.
>> 그렇죠. 왜냐면은 좀 센스도 있는 거
같고 자기만의 이제 툴도 있는 거
같고
>> 그러니까
>> 기존에 뭔가 통념하고 좀 바를 것
같은 그런 느낌이 있습니다.
>> 그니까 음
>> 내 거는 요정 안 맞아. [웃음]
오가장 고마워.
그러자 화수목 중에 수요일 정도나
떼서 하루는 우리 오신날도
신기한 차트 분석 찾아뵙는 거 그렇게
하겠습니다. 그 영상을 또 주말에
다른 분들도 또 보실 수 있게 주말
영상으로도 업로드 하고 막 올 거.
자 그러면 어 시장 분위기는 야
코스피 계속 강세가 이어지네요.
>> 네
>> 그리고 확실히 좀이
반도체 온리장에서 약간 확산되는
분위기인데네
>> 오늘도 확산되고 있는데요. 뭐
조선주나 증권주나 다
>> 정권주 다 올라가냐?
>> 유통주도 그
>> 유통도 올라가고 그죠?
그래서 7월이 [목을 가다듬음]
아 여러 가지로 이래요. 왔다 갔다
하면서 좀
알겠습니다.
자 오늘 채슬리 모니 브리프는
여기까지 하고요. 이번 한 주도 저희
채슬리와 함께 행복하고 슬그롭고
여유 있는 그런 투자 하시길
바라겠습니다. 고맙습니다.
감사합니다.